now a master of the material universe
the Internet has been melting with
almost half a million hits for max
prince qi's demonstrating the world's
most wonderful material without pressure
it just loves fruity eyes he has just
taken his own body heat and used it to
carve through ice like it was butter
this is my absolute favorite clip
because it contains my personal favorite
material graphene and what is this
wonder stuff
we used to see in carbon in the form of
graphite in things like pencils
now graphene is one single awesome thick
layer of exactly the same substance what
max has got here is something called
pyrolytic graphite and this is where you
take single layers of graphene and then
you stack these layers on top of each
other so you get something that's about
quarter of an inch thick what this
material is really good at is conducting
heat
so if heat is essentially atoms
vibrating quickly then how is the heat
getting from his hand to the ice cube if
we could look in and see the atoms in
this material then the atoms that were
next to Max's hand would be vibrating
very quickly and because of this highly
ordered structure one atom would then
bump into the next atom and would
transfer these vibrations straight down
the material really quickly transferring
this energy to the ice cube
okay Sujata let's see how hot your
fingers are now all I'm gonna do I'm not
even gonna reply much fresh dice the
greatest thing this is just sliding
through like a knife through butter
oh wow this is so cool sorry I am
geeking out up in there take this away
from me
I really wanna